this video is sponsored by liquid IV
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we are going to
watch a movie that is not a horror movie
even though I'm joined by scream Queen
Roxy scri over here it's a horror movie
for me because even though I haven't
seen a trailer I don't know what this
movie is about everyone has told me who
I've said I I might do a reaction to it
has been like good luck editing that
you're going to have to blur it I have
no idea what we're walking into right
now I I don't really know either I hear
that there's some some action going on
but could be some action or some AC I
don't I don't know what what are we
watching hey leave a like on this video
subscribe click that Bell what did you
think of saltburn is it good thanks to
prepper for uh doing the hard work here
and I'll I'll see what I can do to help
out with the Ed on this one prepper is
the hard one here oh okay I got the
raunchiest person on here no no I'm I'm
being I'm being koi I'm beating around
the bush uhhuh if we can keep that kind
of level of Comedy up we might be able
to get ad suitability perfectly fine
here but full link through watch 3 with
your own copy of saltburn is available
for a super sexy rejects over our
patreon page thank you to all have been
joining us and over there John and I
cover several things exclusive with
highlights and watch alongs included
last thing I'll say is uh I watched
always Lola I had a big talk with Roxy
about it uh just before filming I have a
hard time uh seeing past a friend
whenever they are performing I've just
seen the character I had several people
tell me who had seen it like she's
actually really great in it and I can
affirm for you guys I told her about a
couple of scenes that I was actually
moved to Tears by so yeah and then he
tried to kick me off the channel yeah
then I said I said you shouldn't be here
you should pursue your career good luck
darling be on your Merry way I really
appreciate it it feels weird to say that
during salt burn you know I expected a
burn from you but I guess no salt in the
Ws dramatic and I'm like oh I better be
more soft and sensitive to her now no it
was really
nice this is maybe the most
controversial movie of last year right
Herald fennel is a goddess I love
promising young woman and I love
her oh my God those are bar Keegan's
lips I wasn't in love with
him
but I
wasn't I loved him of course did you
watch euph Foria yeah he's great in it
and that was part of the problem he
looks like Daniel De le loved him yeah
Jacob all Lord is a stud and exhausted
him people just wouldn't leave him alone
especially the girls it was embarrassing
really how everyone fed over him this
feels like out of a different era this
must be an obsession film that's why he
liked me so much I protected him I was
honest with him I understood him oh God
I loved him I loved him what's the movie
with the peach call me by your name yeah
it's given call me by your name but was
I in love with
him okay what are we looking
at oh
damn okay oh so it's like an
intentionally supposed to feel like out
of a different era especially with the
uh the frame
[Music]
Dimensions it's like call me by your
name me Talented Mr Ripley oh Roseman
Pike's in this she's great as
well richardy Grant shut up these are
great
actors Carrie Mulligan oh she's
amazing good job Carmel Roxy and I will
give extra commentary today to make sure
there's something to show in this
YouTube video
ahuh it is weird the the like glitching
of it of the text yeah or it feels like
old film a kind of both yeah feels like
film re yeah wonder what the choices for
that what are we in Oxford like what's
the
deal wow Emerald fennel produced it too
what a stud have control over the film
Margot Robbie co-producer in one of her
movies huh and she's having a killer
year the where's the runchy stuff hey
cool
jacket and then they
bone my
husband okay class of 2006 so now we
know when we are no wonder it looks like
a 1970s
movie it all makes sense
now juicy W 2006 juicy was still hot
maybe in the UK not here in
America and he was he's wearing Ralph
Lauren all right Jacob Lori you say
Lauren Ralph Lauren it's not
Lauren let's talk about that for the
next 30 minutes just to fill the time
Ralph Lauren Ralph Lauren yeah it is
Ralph Lauren wow this looks like
Hogwarts it does sure every American
thinks that when they see this where's
the sworting Hat 10 points for
Gryffindor
we should have seen this in the theater
drunk that would have been fun wi
Guardian
[Laughter]
Lio I'm Michael Gaby Oliver Oliver
Oliver quick so you're a Norman no mates
too then Oliver quick what are you
reading uh I'm reading maaps I'm a
genius a modest genius ask me some n
you're okay come on it's it's not like I
I don't believe please come on no I
believe ask me then you chose the wrong
table was he assigned here 423 * 78
32994 how would he know if it's real or
not did you come from Far From Home
Prescott yeah whereb you know where
Prescott
is next to
Estonia it's called back to another
video so how did you get on with the
summer reading list uh yeah okay I think
I've read it all love how in disarray
all this is the whole set any idea where
he's got to he's 20 minutes late now
right well I suppose we better make a
start then I'm so sorry sorry I'm late
it's the guy who picked on him he didn't
pick on him he liked his
shirt Farley start I take it you're not
a relation of uh Frederica start by any
chance she's my mother I knew her when I
was your age when we were both here
freder Ken before she went to America
she's going to be thrilled that I've
being toed by one of her friends oh no
not uh
friend Boop admirer yeah from afar oh
not sure we ever spoke these are my
obsessions it's confessions but you get
it oh I get it
okay shall we
start whoa whoa was that seductive is
that the sexual content are we free by
Browning's last tches to look as if it
were alive oh I love him very good
there's something about him yeah lot of
food for thought there intriguing I told
you a lot of this food for thought so
you're picking apart the style my I say
instead of the substance that's kind of
kind of what lazy it's completely valid
to debate the rhetoric of an argument
it's not what you argue but how great
Point very true very true especially if
you haven't actually read the
poems look forward to hearing your essay
oh we thought this guy was just a meek
boy but he is not no I feel like we're
getting like a werewolf story like a
dude is just like's going to build into
some monster by the
[Music]
end he's the outcast in this group did
you know there was a college Christmas
party tonight NFI me and you not invited
you get an invite in your pigeon Hall I
haven't checked I have he didn't
ohing ERS like we wanted to go anyway as
if we actually want to talk to those
vapid I love the like morbid comedy here
o good song Let's
go so a deals with like desire daning
Christian yeah desire were
you desire Obsession and classism all
the things you're great
it you all right um yeah I've got a flat
tire he's in his actual voice look I'm
not really going anywhere just give your
bike taking these back to the library
taking my bike I it looks like rain I
wouldn't I wouldn't want honestly it's
no big deal you're my college so am I
yeah not noticed a are you sure I mean
it's a bit of a FF willing get back to
college you want me to take yours back
oh no no no I just I'm sorry I just
thought I thought I mean I can with it
back to college it's it's not
a dude I'm Felix Oliver Oliver Oliver I
love you I
love so Jacob all Lordi likes to play
people who are lusted after yeah but in
Euphoria he's like a known dbag yeah
here it's like a subtle Jameson spends
the whole time staring at it completely
ignoring the fact she can barely do a
Time's table not exactly does in company
going for a slush get me another pip
please Oliver man this this guy's just
pushed around where's your agency
Oliver oh there he is Ol Oliver
Oliver are you talking to me
me this Oliver hi mate all right this is
my hero right here I was just telling
everyone how you save M oh he's right
next to
him see I owe you a drink here show up
yeah I'm sorry you with friend uh no
they're just left
dude it so it begins talk about a burn
huh but if I was a friend I would walk
over and be like
what I'm in what are we doing tequila I
feel like England's not a teila
place what was
it bombs hey it's your round man I
should go to bed no you can't snake your
way out of a ground I'm not it looks
like you
are there's this great sense of like
percolating anxiety underneath the
surface of all of this just cut him and
break me what and that round's going to
cost a fortune [__] looks actually a
Lord's Australian he's doing a British
accent here okay yeah yeah yeah could I
just pay in tomorrow sorry mate you're
not even close
please thought you might need a hand
with these ones mate when you drop this
a way to protect him I was going to Nick
it but I thought I'd do the right thing
that's
sweet pay back
tomorrow you feel like there's chemistry
yeah yeah I kind of do
too see it comes to debauchery he looks
more and more handsome yeah I don't know
what it is about him it's the talent
he's so effing talented and that's
that's
hot yes little smile my little talented
kid
it is nice to see Felix kind of take
Oliver under his wing after Oliver did
do that thing for him at least he didn't
just blow him off goes against cliches
too F's mom m ran away to America when
she was 19 to escape the cold hearted
English yeah s ah don't
smoke yeah he will now she had up the
wall and a fat chunk of dad's money too
until he had to finally cut her off he
decided he would pay for all of far's
education he's been expelled from almost
every school in England foring off the
teachers can't do that what do they
teach you Latin water polo and
abuse
oh do you have any siblings what do your
parents like siblings no this is very
well written and uh my parents I don't
see them that much why just uh they've
got problems what problems mental health
and addiction and stuff dad was kind of
dealing and stuff
dealing
really was it was it awful these are
great scam work man he's so could play
the
prince I don't know which Prince but not
Prince do these guys do actual school
work does anybody in
college mey mo catch a tiger by his toe
if he's let him go
you're out boy
SC there is a palpable sexual tension
between them oliv quick you look
different do I he'll get bored of you
boot liquor rude but not
untrue it's tough being a follower when
you don't really have your own self
identity I'm I'm sorry Felix but no one
wants to sit next to Oliver not oh my
God God he's a scholarship boy who buys
his clothes from oxan harsh that's so
harsh you're such a s sorry oh great
silhouette he's just trying to be
cooler oh my God is he in the room oh
this is from earlier when he was
watching
creepy this is a rather sensory
experience yeah Emerald fennel is like a
very 360 director from all angles all
touches I
feel yeah there's like this like
consistent unease I'm feeling so hot
cool shot I'm cleaning up only rich
people can afford to be this filthy I
never do it yes I will no you won't yes
I will I said I'd do it later Ollie stop
I'm not a child I can do it myself a
should I be caring about Oliver I feel
like he's going to do some dangerous
[__] uh I've got some revising to do I
think I might U I might catch you later
yeah so it begins it's not fair to be
Jacob ay being like that like tall
goodlooking why is it that I would
choose Barry 10 out of 10
times I mean
he's
more break to everyone ja is really good
though is really good yeah but Barry Oh
my God like every he's giving it every
pore has
like I mean this like this this
character already feels so multi- later
like he's like sheepish and shy right
now but you can feel a darkness that can
overcome and overpower a situation
building yeah completely I also think
they're killing the music in this it's
very 2006 yeah but when they were in the
room the music was so quiet and that
they just they understand how to do it I
was just sing a fedix was in uhoh we
supposed to meet yeah they're all at the
Pol
oh okay is he going to do it with her he
didn't say Sorry
God whatever do you have any alcohol I
thought you like me to have I thought
Oliver was repulsive he said would you
like me to have
alcohol a good for them is it no no it
is a terrible situation but good for
Oliver I mean he's think he'll be
that's why she's doing it yeah I don't
think I'll even
register wrong choice
wordss you forgot the purpose of why she
was there oh and he's
rejected that's gross meanwhile he's
cleaned up Jac's apartment but can't
clean up his own vomit what's
happened his dad died how' that happen
cracked his head on the pavement
a probably drunk there's some amazing
symmetry to the shots man yeah is your
mom all right she was completely
incoherent they're going to have to let
you skip exams and you're in no state to
do them now I me you've got to go I'm
not like you Phoenix this is all I have
scholarship right he's thrown his whole
identity into this oh nice Tu thank you
it's a rent
right always check the
sleeves
but still not bad I mean you're almost
passing I hate him God always taking a
chance to take a jab come on them follow
me wait wait wait where where we going
some people just are like magic and
Felix is like magic he's got that
magnetism everybody wants to be around
him very few of us do and I know what
it's like to be that guy you know what I
mean you can affirm this yes yeah thank
you for sure we have this tradition
right when somebody dies we write their
name on a stone and we Chuck it in the
river my great-grandfather started it
when his son died in the war I've only
done it for my dog so far but there's
nothing worse than when people compare
having a dead dog to having a dead
parent does that happen to you all the
time of course so annoying I know he
wasn't comparing but that happens
nonstop DPC rise up we should have a DPC
Twitter I know what it feels like cuz my
dog's
dead so what do I do don't know really
um I guess we could say a few words or I
mean we could just stand here in silence
for a bit and then you just just Chuck
it in it's nice though that he's doing
something for his friend trying to
support him I feel like it also he does
it out of some type of way to make
himself feel better or something about
Felix that there's a hint of
disingenuous and to keep him around well
that can't be good oh he hit the
rock
well why don't you come home with me
come to Soul oh that's the title of the
movie I don't feel weird I don't feel
weird I mean my ni people come to stay
for months at a time and you know what
if you get sick of us you can leave I
promise is he a real friend I don't know
I think he thinks he
[Music]
is
damn we watch a lot of movies where
people are so
rich I know well I don't want to see
poor people on screen he doesn't like it
when people say poor that would be
depressing cuz it's like looking at
friends
gosh Mr Quick you're early got the
earlier train well do let us know next
time you see the gates were not open
that's that's okay we sent someone to
pick you up just the the distance he's
so much above him yeah
I love how uh Oscars constantly in like
in certain scenes yeah certain scenes
they keep Oscars specifically in the in
the shadows except the fact that his
name is Oliver
yes cuz who's
Oscar you're right you're
right red
staircase I accidentally my cousin here
what I think we heard it right we should
have watched this subtitles Green Room
Garden some hideous ruin what an amazing
track broken piano and the music this is
the long Gallery uh dead re dead relies
for Daddy's old
Teddy acting so good in this
bathroom oh by the way we're going to be
sharing a bathroom I hope you don't mind
otherwise you'd be miles away on the
other end of the house oh what's that
going to lead to stuff stuff with them
mom has a F of beards and stubble so I
left a razor for you in the bathroom she
thinks it's unhygienic anything else I
should know about no no just be yourself
other than just no stubbles on your face
M's never existed that's a made okay
let's
go they probably don't have rehab in
Liverpool no gosh or R and Pike is his
mom remember me saying that at the top I
didn't know it was his mom though
Darling where's Liverpool uh North North
yes oh that's Carrie Mulligan M was the
star of promising young woman so she
must have a good relationship with
traumatized oh they come out drunk is
that right that he had to put his down
his mother's throat to make her sick
that's private stuff dude why is guy
always walking at the wrong time and
conversation cuz he walks in quietly
when you're poor that s of thing does
happen a little bit more Wonder oh the
black sheep of the family parents are
Tru addicts I actually understand and
here he is now we were just talking
about you don't be ser really Mary oh my
God he's keeping it on his upper hello
Oliver darling Oh what beautiful eyes oh
how wonderful yeah I told you it you see
oh but darling you're kind about
everyone you can't be
trusted what a great
line has venisha seen you yet oh my God
she'll die she's been draping herself
all around the house all day hoping
you'll come across her as it were do
stop poor boys only just arrived oliv
what a great shot to capture the
awkwardness of this
totally this is my dear friend Pamela
who's been staying with us hey Pamela
doing what are you go and find Annie and
ask about tea which one's that you'll
find it D
an I would love to meet a family like
this though the latest one is some
ghastly Russian billionaire malignantly
ugly of course and she's been held up
here for months hiding from him let's
not talk about
that this is so
awkward yeah but she's killing it right
now just the social anxiety is so strong
dress for dinner yeah it's like it's
like black tie could have brought one oh
no don't be silly I mean have a spare it
would be a waste will he fit into yours
that's right we'll get it sorted I'll uh
I'll get you some I'm really happy
you're here every shot is perfect I
don't know if I mean overly
complimentary but I get like old school
Hitchcock Vibes here just because of how
the build has been so well to like you
just know something it's just going
weird going to be crazier I don't know
what I'd do without elizeth she really
saved me don't bang on about it P
darling you know we're delighted to have
you for however long it is you mean to
stay forever oh no I I think I'm out of
um found somewhere oh well done
[Music]
darling I love living in a bedset in my
20s it's so freeing to live all in one
room and much less cleaning to do oh it
be terrible When You're Gone how will I
cope I could actually stay for a little
bit longer no darling
do and her blue dress is so freaking
fabulous it hurts that is so aggressive
yeah what she did I'm interested to see
how this movie progresses where you see
like how Felix is similar to his parents
it's nearly full you know that means
we're all about to lose our minds is
that what that sorry you must be you
must be
cold wow he just ran out there in his
box like hi see wife likes you so much
you're so um
real of all the words it was the perfect
one even more than last year's
one last year's one last year's one look
I just feel like there's some stuff we
could put in the YouTube video so we're
in the clear from here on out it's all
going to be blurred how would you like
your eggs oh it's f i i can get them not
the eggs
the eggs are made for you and everything
else is on the
side SC what's weird when like the the
servant is uh
judgmental fried over a please shelle's
housekeeper was cleaning one of the
rooms when Shelly walked past the window
and waved at her she waved back before
she realized that Shel was in Italy and
she was on the top FL the house oh stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop I
won't hours lat he drowned oh that's
just giving me
bumps I heard he his sister oh for God's
sake yes of course you did was gly did
he is not what he asked for no bread to
go with that is everything okay o uh of
course yeah it's just um runny eggs I I
get a bit sick from
them oh my
God we're over here Olly is she naked I
can't tell hi mate hey oh this must be
some like dream he's
having let's
go is this real feels like a dream
including MGMT I'm
obsessed out yeah let's have some fun
before we mess things up thistles
everywhere see
it's got a real white
butt doesn't see the sun too often it's
very real I guess that was
real oh my
God the ring he's going to bang this
whole family isn't he we go from super
bad to the
ring oh my
God realistic way of getting Disturbed
whoa what a hell of a shot sick
what a fun
vacation oh he wants to be that popsicle
I take the opportunity the paly plates
do you mean Bernard palac the 16th
century Hugo ceramist yes do you know
him I've always loved his work but I've
never seen anything of his in real life
makes sense the father would be drawn to
him so weird
[Applause]
stop this is an awesome montage cuz
we're really feeling it like all right
look at them really get settled in yeah
and
Vibe oh he's just watching him yeah do
not get
caught if you get caught oh my God I'm
GNA
squeal you know we can't show most of
this
YouTube my YouTube I mean reig Nation
well okay so let's describe it for
them they' seen the movie they know
what's happening this is the scene that
I You' heard about I have Roxy did not
tell me the scene no I'm just letting
you know I've been oh no we're not there
night mate oh we maybe we are I've been
warned about something that's a phobia
of mine and I told Roxy don't tell me
I'd rather just wait to
see oh no I'm so scared Greg I actually
can't oh my God Greg Greg Greg
[Applause]
Greg no no no no it's no no oh that is
so
funny oh God that is
hilarious not the sound oh my
god oh I hate it he ate the paks you
know you know how I feel about liquid
germs the oh the
tub
no is that what you were told about
yes you know I I have a phobia of
liquids the tub liquid he ate the peach
Army Hammer did not eat the peach he ate
the
peach what the come here fingers for
pudding I'm sick the drain is so
gross I hated that I love how we always
have two different responses hated that
I was lesbian for a while you know all
just too wet for me in the end men are
so lovely and dry oh my
God she's so funny lovely and dry she's
so funny cuz cuz what because you're so
beautiful he's going to bang this whole
family or oh no he's like a deviant
Rising what do you think uh Pamela will
be wearing tonight she's gone James
thought it would be better to peel her
away this morning without too much for
scen only so many hints you can drop
yeah she did seem a bit lost oh my God
he's had like some kind of Awakening you
think she was a riot to look at her but
there's absolutely nothing going on
underneath if all of it was true her
stories to the angel seemed a bit
inconsistent at times I thought you
noticed it too oh yes I had
absolutely the emotional blackmail I was
feeling quite guilty about it this
afternoon but you're absolutely right
there was actually something quite
Sinister about her
yes she might be my favorite performance
in this film she's so funny she is
amazingly funny she's so funny Oliver MH
um I love watching his transformation
yeah he weaves in and out of like now
he's just like becoming like well he's
probably had to adapt his entire life
you know he's becoming confident you're
watching him be
molded yeah look at that just like this
shot of like every shot in this Emerald
holy crap like how he was in the shadows
before but now he's embracing the
darkness and he's above yeah it's called
film observations and you want to be in
a see-through night dress underneath my
window wow this is all playing like a
fantasy you're not eating anything yes I
am well you're not keeping it down I
mean you're so beautiful Venicia you
need to look after yourself oh so
tomorrow you're going to eat and then
you're going to stay at the
table do you
understand that was not what I was
expecting
there I think he's going to eat
now oh what was that I could just eat
you yeah oh my God it's going to eat her
it's not the right time of the month is
there something you think I'm worried
about but your first time come on man
couldn't care less oh my
God it's lucky for you
H oh my God oh my God I used to ask
myself what would ever do every month
wow wow he is a
vampire that's a bold move movie so for
those who can't see what's happening on
YouTube there's
blood I got to tell you Rox this not my
cup of tea are you kidding this isn't or
that isn't I mean you know
either what you know I'm just like in
heaven right now are you I like that is
not my thing right there only because
what's sexy is like it's her body and it
just is what it is and if he doesn't
care it's just I mean roll tide roll
respect for you enjoying
it oh no Jacob Lord is watching you
stupid little boy oh no
what are we looking at
whoa what was that shot artistic I mean
it was him in the bath with the blood on
his face oh that was real it seemed like
like a what was that art artistic
sh I was lost
gr wait who is coming to dinner again
the Henry who the Henry's dad's friends
they're all called
Henry little baby by Henry well I'll put
you next to Oliver then he can you
instead what kind of party I don't know
whatever you want about a 100 people 100
or two it's invariably ends up being two
doesn't it with this sort of
thing oh oh how about fancy dress oh yes
I can wear my suit of armor eleth good
idea
Dary oh no and he tried to talk to Felix
but Felix wasn't having it and I wonder
if the cousin told him or what's
happening what do you think getting with
Phoenicia Ollie what makes you think I
got with Phoenicia Farley saw you too
you're my friend you're supposed to be
here with me I didn't want to embarrass
fenicia embarrass he's going to say she
threw him I saw her outside and I went
down to see was she okay and I think she
got the wrong under the stick because
she tried to kiss me wow oh my God he's
the villain
well why didn't you tell me I I thought
it'd be nicer not to she was hammered
probably doesn't remember she's so
embarrassing you can push him about too
I'm rooting for him yeah he was my best
friend at school and he came to stay
with us and he kind of developed a
little thing for venea and I know
everything just got so awkward kind of
ruin our friendship oh it's kind of
threatening so smart because he asked
why Felix knew he hooked up with fisha
because if if Felix had seen him he
would have had to Pivot but he knew
Felix didn't see him oh my God she's
trying to draw him out right
now
y it's interesting cuz Felix's girl was
trying was hooking up with Oliver
earlier to try to get Felix jealous yeah
and now Felix seems I don't know if the
right words jealousy but a bit of a
jealousy of like the attention and stuff
what I'm trying to figure out is if
Felix has any feelings for Oliver at all
I don't think so you don't think so no
but I be I'd like it though if you think
Oliver has feelings for Felix I mean
Oliver th% has feelings for Felix making
me come to you with a begging Bowl when
are you implying why don't you ask Liam
and Joshua who the are Liam and
Joshua your footman that is low Farley
Jesus Christ mate seriously is that is
that why you want to take this I mean we
your family we hardly even noticed that
you're different or anything like that I
never know how footman's names could
have used a better choice of words my
father has been more generous than most
people would would be a lot more and
maybe maybe we've done all that we can
wow he
succeeded or at least oh my God he is
great I I I'm on his side I I want him
to bring it all crumbling to is this the
dinner with the Henry's or is this this
the party that they're talking about
theity oh great shot is it his party
birthday party or the Henry's party well
maybe we just need to be a bit more
careful no thanks you're just another
one of his toys I mean he never lik
sharing his toys even the ones he
doesn't want to play with anymore
whoa I'm So Into the music what this is
wild
[Music]
a this is so cringe oh my
God all right this I'm going to get a
drink me
too
is there's some stuff that Goa his
sister or his cousin it's his sister I
thought I don't know either way it's
weird I I I think even unless when he
was saying IED my cousin he meant
Venicia yeah let's make sure to mute
Roxy on finger there guy I didn't know
if finger was a you know but the
intention of
what why did you tell Felix about me in
Venicia well I didn't think he react
that badly yes you did yes I
did oh my God are is is I did not if you
ever want to talk to anyone you can talk
to me fary what do you mean well going
through a hard time at home I know how
that feels things are so precarious he's
the devil un lonely and it must be so
and weird having to ask them for
everything if I can help in any way just
ask clever right I think I'm going to go
put him out of his
misery wow that manipulation he is so
good remember when he said that that
other woman might be lying about her
past mhm do you think it's possible he's
lying oh about his family's mental
health and all that stuff that he was
saying no I don't think he's lying about
his past I think it's that past that
that making him do what he's doing yeah
I'm
your you buy me things I never want
anything it's easy curreny we
spend
you pay my
rent I love you you pay my
rent W that is mean this is your song as
well fary come finish it oh my
[Music]
God cringe cringe
cringe what the [__] are you
doing what you think I'm doing Wedding
Crashers I think we're in the wrong room
mind looks like a vase are you going to
behave from now on Farley
no oh my god wow are you going to
B
no is this the right answer to get what
I
[Laughter]
want I'm going to
pay oh my God I would say the people who
said this was runchy are correct
although we're not always seeing I feel
like you for you show is worse I mean
it's
outrageous what a cool shot to say that
he'd come by some pacy plate I mean the
idiot he had to have known that dad went
to school with the chairman mom and dad
would give him anything he asked for
yeah well obviously he got sick of
asking i' been here
yes oh bliss bliss bliss bliss bliss
bliss bliss baby I used to hang out with
them all actually when I was modeling
Brit pop blur oases goth parties but
then of course common people came out
and everybody thought it was written
about me hate common people I mean I
barely knew Javas peasants but she came
from Greece she had a thirst for
knowledge it couldn't have been me I've
never wanted to know what an insanely
gorgeous shot God I wish we didn't have
to go to London I didn't know you going
to London Pamela's funeral Pamela died
should do anything for
attention she has the best lines man the
delivery she has the absolute best lines
and best delivery it's that one two
punch she do anything for ATT Jesus
Christ the N comedy for her is so great
I don't think I'll ever forget that
line this is like an erotic Thriller and
uh it's interesting seeing like the the
one who uses sexuality to overpower
being this character like he's in a very
unusual character to be that Vice for it
usually I don't know I kind of Imagine
like hot woman or something like
that yeah but he's so unassuming and
just I'm telling you he I don't know
every time I ever brought it up
everybody's like what him for you and
I'm like I don't know what it is there's
just something it is the talent I do
know what it is he's just if you said he
can have it but it seems like he
actually loves Felix yeah but he thinks
that's not even on the table it is like
calling by have you seen Talented Mr
Ripley it's a little It's a combination
of like those two films to me morning
birthday boy get dressed we're going on
a road trip what I'm a surprise wear
something nice oh my God sugar
daddy sugar daddy wear something nice
okay Daddy whatever you
want
it's killing me how much further is it
it's not too far now pleas please tell
me Felix I look ol just just hear me out
all right just hit me out oh
Prescott you left your phone in the
bathroom so I thought I thought I I sort
of just picked up I mean you've been
ignoring your calls for weeks and I I
just thought that maybe I could help oh
no please turn the car around you can't
take me now I'm starting to wonder if
the if he lied now I'm starting to
wonder here can you please no I'm not
taking no for an answer mate I'm sorry
that that is very imposing dude yeah
that very imposing oh well this is nice
M look she's cly cleaned up her ass this
is lovely SN
saltburn oh my God yeah he might he
might have created a whole lie let me go
in without you please I'm not leaving
you mate we're in this
together this is one of the best movies
of 2023 for sure I see what the hype is
about this is a great movie if I called
that I'm almost too good it's very much
like I mean you haven't seen the movie
but yeah there is a talent to mrly VI
I'm just going to keep saying
it I'm so nervous me too I'm so
nervous Oliver I didn't recognize you
happy birthday love you must be Felix
it's so nice to meet you your father's
in the garden his
father called
it d
oh that was in MOS we go every year oh
my God I fell for his lies not anymore
kids are all grown up did you told me
you were an only child all of it no he's
been a massive liar I'm not surprised if
he didn't he always wanted to be an only
child or was beatling off by himself
they didn't know what to do with him at
his school he was so clever that's why I
think he found it hard to make friends
oh my God he's a sociopath he's the top
scholar at
Oxford the top scholar he real Li to
them God he's so modest you know I I had
no idea it's been hard not seeing it
well there must be a lot of pressure
though I expect oh yeah yeah of course
it he knew how to use that pity to get
in I've got these horrible migraines why
don't you like turn upstairs darling I
made you bed in case you got to get back
your mother spent all morning making
lunch it does matter of course we can
stay we would love to stay the
resentment did job aori is bomb in this
movie awesome
yeah oh [__] if I were jaob I wouldn't
bring him back home with me let me just
explain I think the best thing is that
you go home after your party I will see
you back at Oxford and we can still be
friends though I mean we're going to
laugh about they why you're fing liar
Ollie wow where does like the next 40
minutes go this is so fascinating can
you not tell your family please of
course not hell it's dark enough as it
is some people just be Liars I he's like
a path logical liars I'm so upset that I
knew he was
lying yeah I even fell for it but it
totally lines up with his character yeah
completely does damn Rock's two in a row
you've been acing
this oh my God he's getting worse look
at that duality of it oh that's great
that is awesome
Duncan
Orchid this movie gets like cooler as it
goes this is a really great movie uhoh
it's George's da uhoh uhoh oh dear and
it is kind of like a horror movie but
you know the one thing that it does ask
us to do is like root for the rich
people at some point but then Oliver
ends up being not poor so I don't know I
think there's interesting challenges the
movie poses CU and I think casting Jacob
a Lordi from Euphoria is so smart
because it automatically me I bet he's
an [__] but he's not he's so so like
conventionally attractive yeah and Rich
but then you end up finding out like oh
actually I talk to you for one
second you can't ignore me forever I can
try Felix come on man TR ni me somebody
else
fair oh
H
oh that was wild
hello F how did you know it was me
Signet ring God you really do notice
everything yeah this place Oliver's once
in a lifetime hand up on a hay bale
golden Big Boy Summer and you'll cling
on to it and comb over it and you'll
wonder how you could ever get it back
but you don't get it back damn you catch
a train to whatever creepy doll fact
creators they make all Oliver is
in this isn't a dream to me it's my
house so whatever happens I always come
back interesting themes of Desire here
good monologue and like how desire can
corrupt
[Applause]
you nobody knows his name nobody knew
his
name
oh they're just here to party
I wonder why they specifically placed
this in 2006 like that's a very specific
like time frame I haven't quite seen yet
what what the purpose of it is it's
probably not the same on social media
fair enough yeah but still current day
enough man it's a multifaceted role this
is a one of the best performances of the
Year kind of like it more than klian
Murphy and alimer I'm just going to
[Music]
say what are we about to watch they're
going into the Labyrinth yeah I think
they're going to the Labyrinth to go do
it and I think uh I think Allie's going
to follow he going to follow a damn look
at that oh my God these like symbolic
like like almost like mythological
hellish shots dresses him for Halloween
for
[Music]
sure and then come talk to
me easy ticket in with Roxy
guys remember the maze map come on
you're smart observant calculated you
can do
it yeah but what's his game plan here
just wants to
watch oh and the statue looking over
them wonder what these animals
mean
Felix what the are you doing here I need
to talk to you were you spying on us no
I wasn't know you two are Ro you think
Felix is going to kill him I don't think
so may be like the the Hollywood thing
to do we need to talk we can't we can't
are you crazy get the away from me look
I just gave you what you wanted everyone
puts on a show for fix so I'm sorry if
my performance wasn't good enough wow
the pathos I just need you to understand
how much I you you're the only friend I
ever had Fenix ever hey doesn't this
just prove how much how much of a good
friend I actually am how well I actually
know you I'm still the same person wow
the way he can make you feel sorry for
him you make my blood room
cold don't don't Ru
this I just think he plays him so human
yeah and I I could see like such a
Hollywood version of this and this feels
like so anti
Hollywood I think you should go to bed
interesting it's like mirroring the stat
at you I love the framing this looks
like Zack Snider's Justice League I was
going to just say I bet he gets cast in
a superhero role real quick he was up
for Superman it does make
[Music]
sense it's very pretty it is wild that
we're not at our third act yet where
it's like what where yeah that's mean
like when that reveal came like wow we
still got a while to go with this
movie uh what happened to Felix I don't
know I was just thinking
that do you think he offed himself would
he I feel like an accident might have
occurred I don't think yeah maybe I
think you're right just wondering
earlier with that line about that oh my
God and Felix was the only one who knew
the truth
yeah they can't find him yeah maybe he
got lost in the Labyrinth you don't need
to be told do
you he ran away away no he wouldn't run
away yeah I just don't want to admit
that he's not here anymore that'd be
crazy you already know you're just
turning the handle on a jacking a box
walking towards the end of the
world it's like he always knew he was
always suspicious of
him oh they're going to bring Oliver in
like he's their own to like replace
Felix kind of thing oh yeah the ultimate
infiltration plan team Felix I mean no
Oscar Oliver God damn it man what's
everyone's
name you good yeah I'm good just so
swept up in the
[Music]
experience they're going to find him out
here oh no it's the end of everything I
was wondering why he was so swave there
like oh
no
did he kill him no I don't think
[Music]
so but did he fall like upside down and
he like choked on vomit or
something there was that one part where
you talked about pills
see he fell what is this statue my
darling boy help me move him we need to
get him inside get him warm uh just need
to get him warmed up super in denial
about yeah come on now help me oh no
this is sad to watch I think we can move
in J I think I think the police yes yes
come away darling it's nearly lunch yes
gosh the way they like go into denial
about
[__] well we were wondering what was
going to happen they're having trouble
they keep getting lost in the Maze Mar
say send one of the gardens to assist
fine Oliver darling why don't you tell
us about last
night cuz they won't bring it up yeah it
was uh wonderful I think it was a hit
don't you darling and that cake was oh
did you like it what now may I be
permitted to close the curtains the
coroner's outside and may need to pass
the window yes thank you close them I
don't normally like chocolate cake don't
look wow last night was so like yes Lynn
has always been an expert with cakes w W
way to keep up this act you have to have
cold hands mhm I oh so but doesn't melt
just talk guys I think that applied more
to pastry than to D just get them
clothed for Christ sake the editing
unreal sound design an editing on this
scene I'm so
sorry
whoa oh my
God oh my God like everyone confronting
lunch is cold you want me just sit e it
like nothing's happening what else is
there to do darling anything
anything sit down and eat the bloody pie
just eat it jeez eat the bloody pie you
wanted to be part of the family you're
not the only person here with feelings
none of us wants your blood American
feelings I think it's delicious wow what
I'm saying is I would feel guilty too
guilty if I was the one racking up lines
tonight someone died is that
true search fall is wrong yes no get out
oh my God what's happening el el don't
you dare look at her get out I won't
mention this to the police man it's like
being stuck in a sensory deprivation
take of I don't think he killed him but
but I don't know do you think he did he
might not remember if he did the way it
was shot made me think no and makes me I
don't know it really could have been an
overdose I don't know yeah I don't think
he would have killed him then again I
don't know I fall for his lies like
everyone
else oh the teddy
bear see you back at the house Oliver
what does that mean don't come with us
he said I'll see you back at the house
right but why not just going together
maybe Oliver looked like he wanted to
spend more time I think as a family
they're doing something to honor him the
rock thing remember yeah yeah I'm just
wondering I think they wanted just to do
this alone as a family
yeah in the end Felix was an all right
guy he was definitely the best of
them what are the chances he sleeps with
at the grave yeah man people acted like
this movie was like nonstop you're do is
it that way do something disgusting and
[Music]
repulsive oh my God Roxy please I I
actually don't want him
[Laughter]
to is he going to I don't know oh no
please just be doing like some bearing
your soul kind of thing okay I think
we're
safe
the actor had to bear his soul for this
and then they were
playing music oh my God okay I think
he's doing it
yeah
wow wow this is really happening what
does it say how did you how did you
possibly predict that that is nuts what
does it say about me that this is the
only movie I've been able to predict all
the things I can't believe this is so
hilarious what is this like expression
of sexuality he's got is anybody going
to see this no okay you people on screen
you know what's happening is he kissing
I he's doing the whole shebang and he's
crying this is a very vulnerable thing
Roxy's here like I wish I was that grave
honestly
amen I'm sorry soing in the ch CH at the
funeral I felt so sorry for you and then
I remembered and I started
laughing I feel like older I remember
then you only knew him for six months
okay you have nothing to do with him
with us with her nothing at
all you're just a stranger it's very
light here you are right in the middle
of it all
stranger danger danger you know what
Daddy started to call you Spiderman
because you're always just skullking
around weaving your spidery
olivery web all fell for the TR love her
I don't think you're a spider I think
you're a snake monster a mo quiet
harmless drawn to shiny things pting up
against the
window oh Felix had that same tattoo you
ate him right up and you
licked
plate but she's drawn to him
too the way he uses sexuality as a
dominance effect I'm broke her
completely she said it herself she
couldn't live without him who do oh my
God wow he has destroyed
everything and now he's on the
bridge but did he do that I mean it is
from The Chain Reaction or did he
literally do it oh that's what you mean
yeah oh no I think she did it herself
but this has to do with her uh with his
actions though man yeah I think it's
time Oliver you to go home discreetly
tonight I just think it's best if I stay
just for the time being holds power over
him you won't go I don't see how I
can my man got to respect the game
respect the game every time you say that
in these reactions it's about the worst
things possible Greg respect the game
how much for you to leave and never come
back to cease all contact with my wife
why because we all have to move on I
know you live under somewhat difficult
circumstances but it's not even really
about the money how much you think he
named it price yeah that's why it looks
all fresh there and uh whatever that
Flash Forward is what do you think the
price was one billion
kajillion uh I don't
know the fact that he actually took
money to leave is wild if he did totally
won he said leave in the night so she
doesn't notice but this is daytime no he
totally
won prising her role from gong girl she
cut her hair so we know it's been a long
time passage of
time he died get back in get back in you
think he's going to try to date her oh
that would be the
best Oliver El smart man oh how handsome
you look I can't believe it that you all
grown up it takes advantage of a
maternal side too I read the news about
Sir James I'm dreadfully sorry that's
why I'm at this coffee shop that I know
you like to see you cuz I'm a
manipulative Ollie I didn't like it the
way James treated you thought about it a
lot and you have to remember that he
wasn't in his right mind then after
everything that happened you do forgive
him you do understand of
course have you been happy not really oh
smart you so smart not really oh my God
genius respect the game Roxy
respect the G seeing her outside of the
saltburn palace is so different now
you're catch hering a very see it feels
vulnerable for her come up and stay get
Sal H respect the game for sure oh my
God Greg stop saying
that I can in the
mirr beautiful shot that been the
happiest of my life who is he talking to
it's just such a shame you got some will
oh knew it but I I I should have said it
I was thinking it damn it so he is he
going to get everything he's going to
get everything it's been a privilege to
look after you just as it'll be a
privilege to look after so and you got
to confess it all thank you for trusting
me I promise I'll look after this house
just as Felix would
have we got there in the end didn't we
no I think he physically must have
killed the other once thank God after
all those terrible terrible
accidents yeah is there really ever such
thing as an accident oh my God
yep accidents are for people like you
for the rest of us there's work and un
like you I actually
know oh my God he is the greatest
villain he noticed oh my god oh he
punctured his tire great villain shut up
great villain our fight club moment
let's see how he did it all I don't have
any money he did could I just pay him
tomorrow he had money ultimate
manipulator he sent an email to soube to
say that he'd come by some pacy plates
yeah we know I knew that I've actually
just bought a little flat nearby blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah I wasn't
in love with him I know Ione thought I
was I loved him by God I loved them but
sometimes I hated
them
he's also
envious I hate
him oh my God he took the rock I hate
all and you made it so
easy spoiled dog sleeping belly up no
natural Predators that's what I'm
talking about man oh he poisoned him he
did kill him my one prediction and he
pretended to make himself
wow
oh like P push the needle forward for
this for the daughter to do it
yeah it was interesting when he was
eating his eggs and he was like the
runny ones make me feel sick and that's
like a rich priv kid thing to say
too would if this set up on alarm in
some way in the
[Music]
house genius what a cold cold film love
it we still don't even know exactly why
he is the way he is makes it all the
more
unsettling this hemp what a perfect shot
perfect
shot you took out the family dude you
got the
estate oh reversing the shot this time
it's
amazing any time it peaks in a frame you
got to look right just
like oh God if he was walking through
being shown it earlier it was like oh
this is he's going to want it if he
wants it he goes after it what a wild
feeling right now it's like is this a
happy ending
I mean just the complete ownership he
has where he can walk like just go
around and naked oh I think is so so
clever it's right we can just adjust the
crop on the reaction so we we don't see
the you
know he caught all the Rocks you sick
twisted
bastard
the real prize possession sick twisted
son of a [__] respect the game
Roxy respect the G all right reject
Nation so today I want to share
something with you that has been a
wonderful addition to my health and
fitness journey that I discovered during
the holidays and that is liquid IV's
hydration multiplier I'm down to my very
last packet and I'm freaking out but
it's okay I got more in the mail now a
lot of you have been so kind to notice
how I've been working on my physical
health thank you for all the compliments
and one thing I learned is that proper
hydration is absolutely crucial
especially post-workout and pre-filming
after post-workout and my wife actually
introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about
quality but a good tast and quality
product so whether it's after a sweaty
workout or just after you know a good
night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm
always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero
sugar added because that's one of my
main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products
that fit that description that also
taste good too so yes thank you so much
so liquid IVs hydration multiplier is in
summary is they are a non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers
hydration into your bloodstream faster
and more efficient than water alone
sometimes drinking a whole gallon is not
always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water also a big
on efficiency plus it's packed with 11
essential vitamins and we know vitamins
are good for the body it's vegan soy
free gluten- free and dairy free you can
customize the water amount to your taste
again perfect for post night recovery
traveling or just having a big night out
you know what I mean noral so if you
want to boost your support for the
channel and boost your hydration game go
to liquid i.com and use promo code
Rejects at checkout that's liquid i.com
promo code Rejects and remember liquid
IV it's not a real IV sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
ladies and gentlemen if you were
listening to this on Apple or Spotify we
just watched
saltburn and uh I'm here with Roxy and
uh wow before watching
this I was told that it was going to be
a hard moveie to blur I don't think so
actually I feel like we can get away
with some of this it's no we near as bad
as as as it was hyped up to be in terms
of like the cuda's sexual stuff I was
like no it's not I mean Greg it goes
there but it's it is so not that
bathroom scene the grave scene and then
the ending scene come
on sure I guess I think I think HBO is
worse I think Euphoria is worse I think
Euphoria is worse by a l I think there's
like some gross out stuff but it's you
do watch alongs for Euphoria no but I've
seen all of euphoria I like I'm just
saying I think that's what yeah whoa and
this like the stakes were just so much
higher too oh my God that was really
good that movie was excellent I I think
that one of the best movies of 20
undoubtedly some sometimes he's like
hyped up Oscar films feel like Oscar
batty [__] to me and yeah this was a I
thought this was a very transportive
wonderful experience that was genius I
think it's a genius movie it's very
genius it doesn't feel pretentious which
is what I was worried it was going to be
because
exactly like Rich
family poor guy and then it's just so
not that yeah that was really good they
did an amazing job with the casting and
then every single shot they made count
and with those things combined plus the
the music to me was just so fantastic it
was just a home run yeah the snaking in
its own tail and the credits here Ora
Boris effect yep um I I I feel like this
would also make an amazing rewatch an
amazing re see what you could pick up on
the little seeds planted throughout
because I think who's this director I
don't know who this director is venel
she's really really good her big thing
was promising young woman um which was
kind of like this in terms of a little
bit of at the end um almost like a
Revenge movie but not a Revenge movie I
think she's on actually gone on the
record to say she doesn't do Revenge
movies but in in the way that this was
like a yeah a gotcha thing I don't know
she's really
good I'm not going to I I'll try my best
to sound like I'm smart here and um you
know I might sound a little bit you know
pretentious or at least trying to be as
we try to you're trying to be
pretentious I'm try to be pretentious as
I try to put on your pretentious
face let me just uh put this
back let me
um be a little
pretentious aha good point sir legs
crossed
yeah okay what do you got pretentious
man
[Music]
as we unpack this movie because it is a
thought-provoking film what I love about
it is this is one where I'm sure that's
it's of course open to interpretation of
what the movie is really all about and I
I thought as the movie was playing out
that I was going to get some things
about like commentary where they're
talking to me about like if [__] the
rich or whatever that it was going to be
one of those movies and to me what I
what I was so impressed by was
that
it's it seems like they put character
motivation first and foremost and that
is really the theme of the movie which
is like desire and Obsession and that is
the character U of uh of Oliver is he is
nothing but desire and Obsession to the
point where he will lie to The Nail
about anything and believe his own lies
and I I found it such a fascin fting
portrayal that you watching this whole
experience through his point of view as
you're unpacking this side of the world
that most of us don't know or can't
experience right and you they throwing
you into his perspective essentially our
villains perspective to see like of
course you would desire something like
you know we always talk people always
talking [__] about one percenters but
that part that pardon all of us it's
like but it might be a little bit cool
to be a 1er right and I think this movie
with that with the audience of like oh
yeah mean Oliver most of don't really
have money don't come from nothing but
man me thrust into this
lifestyle and and but also placing into
the uncomfortableness of being
ostracized for being less than at first
before getting indoctrinated into the
wealthy family side I thought was so
brilliant because he is the villain of
the story but they don't set they don't
tell you that right away he's the
villain though and it it is almost
almost a breaking bades situation where
you're like we're watching The Monster
come into fruition but he was a monster
from the beginning like from the GetGo
he's always been this con artist uh it
was a genius performance brilliant it
might be my favorite um male performer
of
2023 that I have seen I haven't seen
them all I haven't seen like the Paul
Giamatti movie um but to me yeah I think
well I think Kelly Murphy is like the
front runner for Oppenheimer and I think
I thought he was absolutely brilliant in
that film this Takes the Cake this is
the thing like I like that little Joker
teas we got in in uh the Batman but this
made me go oh man I would love to see
this guy as the Joker more than anything
else yeah I definitely feel you in all
of that going back to something you said
a minute ago though what do you feel is
the message of the movie I don't know if
there's a message yeah I know I'm
sitting here trying to like rack my
brain about about what this movie was
trying to say um and I don't think it's
about it was kind of a slice of Life
film exactly and I think that that's
interesting but I do think that there is
there are many lessons throughout um
number one I I'm always so I'm scared
crapless of people and until you you
can't know somebody that quick like
nobody can know anybody that quick and
that is always scary when you see people
that get so close to people with in a
couple of months right a few months and
it's like ooh but who is somebody even
you could know somebody for years and
still not even know them so I do think
this is like a how well do you know
somebody and love versus lust situation
almost too where it's like are you being
courted by somebody or are your feelings
for that person real I mean friendship
feelings romantic feelings as we're
watching this he's just like a a
blue-eyed serpent man like anybody the
mom crushed on him the daughter crushed
on him the cousin crushed on him I even
felt at times that Felix had feelings
for him you know there's moments where
I'm like is Felix into him like he just
was he was that ick guy and when we
started the movie I was like Wow Felix
is the ick guy like Felix is the guy
everybody wants to be around but really
at the end of the day it wasn't Felix
that everybody was
swooning over it it was Oliver I mean it
was both of them in different ways but
like Oliver found a way to hone in on
every person and make them feel seen
that's why he focuses on the daughter's
eating disorder right because he's like
nobody is talking to her about this
nobody's noticing it and in this family
you brush things under the rug so I'm
going to make her feel seen and when he
says that to her like tomorrow you're
going to be eating and not going to the
bathroom after afterwards to purge she
knows that she's been noticed yeah um
and it's the same thing with the mom but
like as he as everybody's calling him so
observant and he's like well you're so
beautiful I'm surprised to hear that
he's just he does such an amazing job of
noticing everybody noticing everything
noticing that the cousin had that ring
on that's how he knew it was him this
the scariest thing somebody could be
right the most observant person in the
room just yeah he was able to get to
everybody in a way that other people are
not what a
snake yeah is it it's a narcissistic
manipulator like to the to the Max and
it is a f it's a fascinating to me this
is and for a film that I don't know what
the aspect ratio is that this film was
shot in um it's not 4x3 I forget what
the dimensions are but for it to kind of
hearken back to like a bit of a 70s
flare it does remind me a bit of like
the crazy sociopathic type of characters
or Psychopathic kind of characters from
the rise of like darker Cinema and so to
see it portrayed here and then captured
in that light I think is grandiose in in
every fashion and Jacob a Lordi was
excellent he just like a guy everyone
here felt so real and to your point
about how he like makes the
manipulations and the tactics of
connection the only one we did not see
him do that with is the dad the only one
he failed at doing that with other than
the one part where you see a a brief
moment they connected over the ashtray
or the artist who made the ashtray right
but that's it but nothing about a truly
personal level of who they are as a as a
human being and he manages to do that
with everyone often in the form of
sexuality like that's how he would
dominate so maybe because he knew that
the dad wouldn't go for the sexuality
and so but but he did with the dad like
in ways where he's like this pie is
really good he knows the dad wants to
keep it surface so around the dad he
keeps it surface yeah he plates so he
can take contr but that is actually
that's probably a really great point
that you just made is like the reason
why he couldn't dominate is because he
uses sexuality to dominate and and in
ways that are like extreme but I love
like this symbolism behind so much of it
of literally just he calls himself a
vampire and he is a vampire and and and
it is like sucking on the blood the
literal fluids of just this ultimate
lust and desire he plays he plays the
whole thing like a vampire and a
werewolf just a werewolf in the sense of
you're watching him become the werewolf
by the end and a vampire and the the way
he prays and sucks the life out of the
family you know like the movie what I
what I love about it is like the movie
kind of just tells you who he is pretty
early on and you think you're watching a
guy transform from sheepish to confident
but really the sheepishness is just kind
of an act act yeah and and so is just
pulling back a layer is what you're
doing with him the entire time like he
is the most fascinating character
surrounded by a bunch of characters who
are so elevated by the other performers
um the cinematography I thought was drop
dead gorgeous is this what her films
normally look like uh she I I'm trying
to think I think there was another movie
I loved of hers before promising young
woman let me just look but it was
promising young woman looked amazing too
amazing so I think that probably but I
think I liked something El that she did
a lot too I'll let you know in a second
um another thing that I think that the
movie did a great job with was the fact
that it he is so untrusting that's why
he calls out the other woman who ends up
um killing herself you know he calls her
he's he says maybe she was lying and
it's a note to all of us that typically
the most untrusting people are the most
uh are the least trustworthy people
because they're projecting killing Eve
that's what I know her from oh heard of
that movie no no that's a show um
killing Eve was that show with Sandro
and um uh that AMC show it was uh I
don't know anything I don't know why I'm
taking all these killing Eve was that
really big show um on AMC with Sandra o
and jod comr jod comr was the one who
kept getting nominated for it maybe
Sandra o did as well but that's where
Emerald venel um I forgot about that
that's where she came before promising
young woman and people really liked her
from killing Eve which is actually a
show that I didn't end up watching then
she did end up playing Seven in seven
episodes of the crown she played um
Camila so she's an actress as well okay
cool she's and she was mij and
Barbie so she has been uh a writer an
actress a producer a director what an
effing Talent what a star this woman is
just like going massive places well this
movie is executed with a level of
awareness and precision that you don't
often really get like I I really love
how completely character driven
everything was in spite of like wow look
at these beautiful costumes look at the
locations they have shot upon like you
utilizing the salurn estate or whatever
the hell it's called in real life uh
absolutely gorgeous and
um the like the the original music
backed with the music tracks that they
decided to use to convey emotion uh was
constantly spot on to represent
everything of what someone is feeling
internally like immediately from the
jump I was feeling this sense of unease
that was kind of also with like I've
heard like risky things about this and
I'm I'm worried about the edit but I
think we'll be fine actually but the uh
the the the uneased though of like the
the anxieties that this movie produces I
thought was so great like there's
there's this sense of like um desire for
sin that casts like a Paul over the
entire film that you feel right away
before anything's even really going down
and there's a lot of great misleading I
think too uh like in the hands of Jacob
all Lordi and everyone else like no one
none of them were bad he's the bad one I
thought that was so CL but they are in
ways right like when we do hear the
cousin to bring up the point to Jacob a
Lordi and he's like I don't want to just
keep having to ask and not while that's
rich people problems and I I it's not
relatable at all I wish I had somebody
Rich that I could go ask to at the same
time it's not like we're watching the
most philanthropic people of all time
get together we're not they're not
making this movie isn't making a
commentary like rich people are actually
really good they're saying that rich
people aren't always the worst one in
the room yeah they guess well I don't
that's the thing is like I don't really
I'm just so fixated on on on Oliver and
what that level of Desire can do of of
of of greed from the perspective of
someone who doesn't have the thing that
you would really want and what levels
you would go through to get what you
want so if anything that's like kind of
the commentary of the desire for greed
that I'm at least Gathering From the
film like by the end when he is dancing
naked and standing over like essentially
his Trophies the rocks that he would go
and collect of of the rocks that just
belong in the ocean that he is almost
the statues that look the way he would
do these certain poses he looked like
the statue of David honestly yeah the
statues that we looking upon yeah I I
thought that was great like he F he has
this like almost God deity complex that
he has about himself of he deserves more
and it's completely dismissive of his
family and I think the way the rich
people are portrayed here is yeah like
they got dismissive
negligent um uh pompous they got bad
characteristics but they're
not they aren't doing what he's doing
like straight up criminal activities you
know he is an ins Ane liar through and
through you know like he he they are
they are rude and evil they're rude and
whatever and but he is a whole new level
of of cunning and I I can't help but
respect the game Roxy I thought the end
scene was phenomenal
because right before that when we see
him in the coffee shop with Roseman
Pike's character she says are have you
been happy and he says no and then at
the end what's incredible is that
usually these movies try to make a
lesson like even when you get you really
want you're not happy mhm like you think
you want it but then you're not that was
the happiest we've ever seen anybody any
character in a movie ever him just
dancing naked throughout the house by
himself that is what he wanted that is
what he got and now he is truly happy
it's like Brut it's just like kind of
unbelievable to see where he's like
because he's because he is really like a
crazy person you know he's really truly
is narcissist really truly is a nut job
he really truly is wants to be rich and
alone and and uh that's what we see and
when he says that he didn't really love
that he wasn't in love with Felix and in
fact he actually sometimes hated him and
hated all of them yeah it's just makes
it even more of a brilliant performance
by the character and a more brilliant
performance by the actor oh he's so good
he was great yeah I've never really been
on the Barry kyogen train that everyone
else especially you are on train I feel
like I've been conducting riding you
know who really is and who kind of knows
him he's a he's a koi individual oh I
knew you're going to say knows everybody
um this this a carpet
situation what does that mean I feel
like they met on a
carpet I don't know I thought there was
like some in over
there like car some dirty
joke uh no I I have no idea uh how they
actually do know each other but uh CO's
obsessed with him cuz he feels like he
represents his Irish representation or
some [__] I mean he's unbelievable he's
really unbelievable he was best part of
eternals too so so good did you see that
yeah know I thought it was really good I
like I think anytime I see him I'm like
he's really good but I've never quite
slingshotted to that I get it now meme
that people do from It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia this was the movie that did
it for me like oh my God this guy is a
genius actor yeah he's brilliant but
especially to just see him like in
banshees of inin is that it's called
inar inter aarin to see him in that
which is a completely different type of
character and thinking about the
versatility of stuff I've seen him in
and then this is the first one I've seen
where he is the leading character uh
yeah this this really uh solidified
something for me because when you're
watching it you get it you get why all
these people are falling for him like it
makes sense and on paper you might NE
not necessarily see it but when he's
alive he's alive it's just really crazy
you there was one he doesn't do it by
sorry to interrupt it was he he does it
in a way where he listens it's not
about how to present himself it you know
he's the antithesis to um Felix where
Felix is all about magnetism of his
Charisma and what he has to offer where
what he does is he knows how to just
listen and connect and and and
somehow identify and let someone feel
understood that is his
power and using that as a calculation I
think is great because normally this
like erotic like Thriller types of deals
are it is about being the one to be
lusted after because of the presentation
and whatever but he just knows how to do
it based off of um connection yeah it's
interesting when we saw him first
opening up to Felix's character he
tested the Water by saying you know my
parents are are addicts and um it's been
a tough life and he saw that Felix
responded to that so when he knew he was
losing Felix that's when he made up that
his dad died yeah because he knew that
Felix would respond to that and not push
it him away he would bring him in closer
like he did because some people want to
hear about trauma and others don't and
uh yeah he he really did he went in I
don't remember the thing that I was
going to say to you before it's okay I
think it was a really bad point or I'd
remember it
really yeah
probably really really um I don't is
there anything else we forgot to talk
about no I think that's it cast great
check thought off directing great
writing solid um music music great we
knocked about that everything so is I I
think come like is there something we
totally missed uh is there something you
didn't
like the if I'm being extremely
nitpicky I thought that the cousin in
his monologue I wish that he had could
have gotten a couple more takes it felt
a little forced I liked the monologue a
lot but the performance on when she was
in the bathtub no that's the sister the
cousin uh oh yeah um what monologue
what's his name trenty trenty um when he
is saying confronting at the part at the
party exactly yeah
uh when I when I said that's a good
monologue I was thinking in my head
that's a good monologue I feel like that
actor could have used a little bit um
that's fair more subtlety in it he he
was a really talented guy it felt like
maybe they were rushed behind schedule
in that one scene it's just a theory of
mine but literally if I'm I'm being that
nitpicky it's one scene not the
performer in general just that
performance in that scene where I was
like I wish we could just slow it down a
little bit there um but that honestly
that's my
only I thought that everything else was
like truly I thought this was close to a
perfect
movie yeah I even honestly even the
handling of the sexuality is is
something that I thought was really well
well done as Extreme as it
is that it might just be chocked up to
shock shock value there are people who
don't know how to truly connect with
themselves uh uh connected people
emotionally so they they convert that
into physicality into sexuality so I
think that is the way how they portray
that here was a very fast even at the
graveyard I'm like this makes sense that
this guy would do that you know like
he's grieving he's having a hard time
he's he's probably gonna do it yeah
that's why when he said it I was like
you know what I wouldn't write it off
like if it kind of makes sense that the
guy might do that uh it of just to feel
the actual Connection in a in a in the
most physical way where you can't really
do it emotionally yeah but it didn't
feel like Emerald chose that for shock
value it felt like that was true to this
character but it's also kind of funny
the way they did it you know so I mean a
lot of this did feel like yeah comedy
drama suspense I agree it's a funny
movie it's a funny movie totally and
unsettling the mom character she was
hysterical I guess I I mean I'm trying
to like find my nitpick about it
uh yeah I don't
gosh you know I don't want to leave you
uh hanging in the dust here I feel like
I got to find a nppi you don't have to
just when you said it honestly that was
the one moment when we were watching I
was like just it was not bad I just
wanted something a little more I think
if when looking back that friend at the
school um the girl no the guy the weird
guy who with the num yeah I don't know
what that was all I mean other than to
represent that he will be that he will
write off I guess it's now that I'm
thinking about it it's like it's
representative of his character the way
he like writes off his family and we
reject and deny them and it's cluing
because it is like cluing you into who
his character is right from the get that
he was like Deuces damn you know what
that is actually really smart and the
guy's like you look different yeah and
the way the movie misleads it's like
yeah I was trying to find a criticism
like but you know what here's why it's
brilliant actually what they did cuz
he's even warning you you think the
movie will go with One Direction but
that's why when I realized like we I was
aware of the Run time and then when I
saw we were only about 80 to 90 minutes
in yeah that was crazy and then Jacob
all Lordi found out the truth I was like
wait a minute where's this movie going
yeah but when even at that you were like
do you think he killed him and I was
like like right after that and I was
like I don't think so and then it's like
yeah he definitely did once the dad was
dead I did suspect that it was the mom
he was talking to um cuz I was like who
else would he be talking to uh I thought
maybe the police because I think I
believe and somebody correct me if I'm
wrong I believe Emerald fennels father
is a police officer which is is had
relevancy in um promising young woman
and I and I had read some kind of
interview about her talking something
about that like somebody asked her is
that difficult for her whatever whatever
it is cuz obviously it's 2024 so people
have their feelings about the cops but
um I thought that they were that was
they were asking that question because I
thought it might be relevant to this
movie like maybe he was being tried or
questioned or something but I completely
missed the mark on that and so I
couldn't even think about him talking to
Mom because I was like oh he's talking
to cops in a suit that's so weird why is
this maybe it's lawyers instead like
yeah yeah but I was wrong I didn't
predict that out loud so I could have
been wrong to myself and never told you
guys that but I I wanted to be honest
with you unlike Barry Keegan what having
Run tomatoes that's the last thing I'll
let you go Roy I would guess it's very
high on Rotten Tomatoes I would guess I
would guess low audience score I would
say the critics are probably high I
would probably say this is probably an
807 I would say mid audience score what
beekeeper has pretty damn good
reviews I was not expecting that okay go
find go find this I did not expect that
I really am so surprised oh 71 I thought
it'd be a little higher oh my God the
audience score I way off here too
audience score is higher than the critic
score
candy coated and incisive salurn is a
debauch jol to the senses that will be
invigorating for most huh sounds like a
passive sounds like Ron Tomatoes sounds
like Ron Tomatoes themselves to say
something to me
yeah I think most people enjoy sof is
really intense easily gross out or
offended this probably isn't for you I
don't feel like the gross stuff is
barely in the movie I think that that's
crazy that you keep saying that it's
barely in it's like it's like short if
you think about a two 2 hour and 11
movie it's probably like 10 minutes of
the movie I don't feel that way at all
if you take the calculation of the time
run of those scenes is barely in the
movie I don't feel that way are you only
talking about sexual stuff because yeah
no I mean there's a lot of violence too
like somebody violence think about her
in the bathtub like that's horrific to
watch think about him with the at the
end with the mom that's horrific to
watch think about like when they're
saying the easily grossed out stuff
you're grossed out by that by somebody
covered in blood in the tub yeah that
was I feel like I've seen in like a
billion I mean yeah it's disturbing yes
I'm not going to I'm not going to write
that off as like you know I've seen [__]
I'm a cop or something you know I'm just
saying I saw a spit that just came out
of my mouth I didn't see it but I drew
attention to it out of uncomfortableness
lot I think there's a lot in this that's
like whatever people have talked about
it they've said like it's the sexual
stuff that and to me that's where my
mind kept going I'm like that's not that
bad what are you looking for I don't
know doesn't matter all righty guys I
got to get Roxy out of here uh what did
you guys think of salt bur what's your
interpretation of it leave your thoughts
down below uh Roxy thank you for driving
here and sounds like 90 minutes of
traffic no it's okay it's not your fault
brutal it's not your fault oh is this
Goodwill Hunting hm Goodwill Hunting oh
we're doing Goodwill Hunting they not
your fault you got that yeah I got to go
see about a girl you Boston
freaks I like that's your Bible right
there at Goodwill I got her number um
and leave your thoughts down below watch
always Lola appreciate you being here
see y'all
soon Chris Wham off Chris Chris Wham off
my man it is
2024 and at the end of
2023 this guy this guy I think to our
live streams I think he contributed like
over $2,000 at minimum at minimum so for
2024 here's what you're going to do
you're going to sue us so you can earn
that M I'm talking small claims court
man there's a way where you can do it
you can be like they somehow hacked my
system misappropriated funds by hacking
me you could blame us and then you can
earn more it's actually a wise con that
you can totally pull off cuz it makes no
logical sense to give that much money
sure you must be insane yeah like all I
got to do is like why would I do that
why would I give that I'm getting
married I have a hot Filipina fiance why
would I possibly give $2,000 to these
random people on the internet I've never
met in person that would be totally
ludic careless of my financial spending
habits to have done such a thing when
I'm trying to start a family right now
why would I do that why all they would
do is mock me for giving them
$2,000 CH you're a sucker Chris wh off
you're a sucker and we got you no man
you've been amazing he's got a beautiful
penoy pry baby you're going to win it
back after Joy Koy destroyed it for all
of us you're going to win it all back
man Noy it's okay and uh I hope you have
some beautiful haa babies it's going to
be great man you know keeps keep you
know watering down the this litter of
the Filipina blood that's right you know
right white men stepping in ruining it
for us that's what I am I'm half my dad
was the white one oh okay and my mom was
the Filipino one good yeah John didn't
know all for 20 years that's why his
response was like oh okay I didn't know
wow inter I couldn't ever sell
fascinating SW your dad was Filipino I
guess that's just be be
blind um yeah but no Chris man I hope
that this year you save wisely and that
you're able to have that dream
destination wedding and maybe buy uh buy
me a ticket to go to the Philippines for
your wedding John will save up and I
will and I'll fly myself out I'll find
my own hotel I will I will do Babble
lessons on on you know toal it'll be
great they're pretty much bilingual out
there John I will not rest upon my
privil g
i appropriate myself
into probably be fine honestly then why
are we already going to the Philippines
we could we could shoot there and uh
make sure you get me two beds just so
that way I could tell John sorry man I
just don't want you in this room I yeah
that is for my luggage that b is so my
luggage doesn't have to touch the floor
that way I don't have to shuffle through
a closet I just don't I just want it
right there under this cover ready at a
moment's notice yeah I just and we're
ready to go which is just smart thinking
yeah efficiency that's why Steve Jobs
always wear black shirts that's all I'm
going to pack it's the same shirt of BS
i' be like sorry man he need ready to go
any he's got just 100 vacuum sealed
shirts and pants black shirt turtleneck
brown slacks ah buddy well I love you
Wham off and I hope that you're able to
uh you know keep getting uh keep getting
your your M Wham off you know what I
mean bam think you m
off is that what you say after you
finish the deed Wham
off the Wham off deed wh off off wh
off flame on anyway show her this I'm
sure she'd appreciate this more than you
will happy uh New Year
[Music]
buddy